[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
opening statements are presented as an
accused serial killer stands trial in
texas you're going to hear about how
this individual right here attacks not
just one not just two but three
different individuals leaving them for
dead but first johnny depp is back on
the stand with his fourth day of
testimony the only person that i have
ever abused in my life is myself plus
depth cross-examination gets heated
2017
is a pathetic attempt mr depp please
just respond to the question that i'm
asking you and later it's nothing that
anyone should have to
sustain for any length of time when
you're being
demeaned berated
judged we are live in fairfax county
virginia for week three of debt verse
heard law on crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer the johnny
depp and amber heard defamation trial
stretches into its third week with depth
back on the stand for a tough
cross-examination monday morning law on
crime's angel libya is here with some of
those tough questions angenette
yeah brian the cross-examination began
monday morning with amber heard's lawyer
ben rottenborn playing audio clips in
which depp and heard were arguing and
heard was claiming that depp had abused
her depp then shouted back at her using
vulgar language but to wrap up his
cross-examination he presented some
evidence a stack of
articles news stories that alluded to
depp's career going downhill before
amber heard ever wrote that washington
post op-ed back in 2018.
for years prior to the date that miss
heard wrote the op-ed there were
numerous negative news stories about you
you'd agree with that correct objection
compound
a sustained compound for years prior to
2018 when amber wrote the op-ed there
were numerous negative news stories
about you that were released into the
public correct objection calls for
speculation
aloud if you can answer
um by 2018 you're saying correct
yes it all started with um miss heard
going to
going directly to a court to get a tro
which is
with a bruise on her face and paparazzi
uh that that was the sort of beginning
of the
the ball
rolling down the hill and gaining
momentum there were lots of negative
stories about you prior to may 27 2016
when amber went into court correct
objection asked answered
now it's 2016. i'll allow it if you can
answer it there are plenty of negative
stories about you
prior to that date weren't there
so i've
i've been in this
the racket of hollywood since 1984.
um
my
mr david that's
i'm asking you a yes or no question
there were plenty of negative news
stories about you prior to may 27 2016.
correct
from 1984 up until then they're all
they're both
so
of course people write negative stories
now one of the audio clips that ben
rottenborn played for the jury was a
clip in which amber heard told johnny
depp that he had put cigarette butts out
on her or lit cigarettes i should say on
redirect though depp's lawyers played
longer portions of those clips and
johnny depp was told by amber heard
repeatedly moved to the couch moved to
the couch and then he said that he got
his cigarette on
her i can
certainly say that
without hesitation
there is no
way
under the sun that i would
flick a cigarette at her or burn her
with a cigarette
if i flicked ashes
and an ash
got on her but she's certainly not
screaming out in pain as if a cigarette
is being put out on her
that's
ludicrous
now several more audio recordings were
played on redirect by johnny depp's
lawyers and in one johnny depp told
amber heard that he didn't want to be
with her anymore amber heard was crying
and said essentially that she would die
without him brian
just a few questions depp's colorful and
correctly saying uh vulgar language was
a focus on cross examination but do bad
words pull this case into abuse
well according to ben rottenborn bad
words do
pull it into abuse he started the cross
examination on monday morning by asking
johnny depp where whether domestic abuse
can
be verbal or emotional not necessarily
just physical and he said yes some of
those vulgar
words were played on the audio tapes but
then on redirect they kind of clarified
some of that obviously he uses a lot of
vulgar language we've heard it in the
text messages we've heard it in the
audio clips and you have to wonder what
the jury is making of all of this yeah
and and let's talk about those new
recordings that were introduced on
redirect how do you think those move the
case giving some context to the kind of
drunken pirate language that he might
have been using
well it's interesting because on the
cross examination it appeared that ben
rottenborn was playing pretty brief
clips on redirect longer clips were
played by johnny depp's
attorney and i think that you did get
more context as to what was going on in
those conversations at the time
now depp is off the stand as of monday
more witnesses coming afterwards but how
did his attorney end that redirect
examination
it seemed to be a pretty powerful way to
end it she had played a clip in which
johnny depp had recorded a phone call
with amber heard and amber heard had
said something to johnny depp to the
effect of go ahead johnny tell the world
you're the victim of domestic violence
and his attorney asked him the final
question
are you a victim of domestic violence or
what do you say to that and johnny depp
says i said
i am he said i am a victim of domestic
violence and that's how it ended yeah a
powerful way to end that redirect now i
think everyone's expecting for the next
major part of testimony and hopefully
that's going to be amber hurd taking the
stand soon and janet will be right back
with you still ahead on law and crime
daily our coverage of the johnny depp
versus amber heard defamation trial
continues and depp gets fired up on the
stand as cross examination comes to an
end here they heated back and forth
after this
[Music]
welcome back we continue now with our
johnny depp amber herd coverage
cross-examination continues to a heated
end on monday when depp pushes back
against herd's attorney
take a look at the the stack of articles
in front of you
yes it's a stack of hit pieces the the
first one
is
just a city team the first one is
entitled uh it's from the guardian you
see that
apparently drunk apparently drunk johnny
depp
cut off at hollywood film awards
ceremony correct
that's what it says yesterday in the
next article johnny depp reportedly
drank heavily and was constantly late on
the new pirates movie set did i read
that right you do reportedly the next
argument will also be made
2017.
the next document headline johnny depp
allegedly showed up drunk to movie
premiere reports say did i read that
correctly let's say
this is hearsay the last one vodka for
breakfast
72 hour drug binges and spending sprees
that beggar belief
allison boshoff reveals why hollywood's
reeling over what's being called johnny
depp's career suicide note who's alison
beauchelf and how does she know
you you became associated with those
domestic abuse accusations that she made
against you correct i think that's clear
and you understood that she became
associated with those same accusations
that she made correct you testified to
that
well
she had a choice i didn't
joining us today is legal analyst karen
nance co-host terry austin and long
crimes anjanet levy karen does depth
getting angry on the stand hurt him or
do you think that heated exchange made
rottenborn look bad
i believe it made rottenborg look bad
because he is the attorney he's the one
that should keep his calm and he would
cut off uh mr depp when he was trying to
answer the question it's understandable
that a witness who's not familiar with
being in the courtroom would say some
things and not know the protocol but you
put the onus on the attorney and he
seemed angrier
mr rottenbord more so than johnny depp
did john depp did have his exchanges but
he was um
still relatively calm i would say he
wasn't uh didn't appear any angrier than
mr ron
did yeah just stylistically you've got a
likable witness it's the same thing as
if you're doing a forcible touching case
of a small child you gotta tread lightly
terry herd's attorneys have shown the
jury messages where depp says he cut his
own finger but depp says that's just
poorly worded what do you think the jury
will believe
well i'm glad they talked about that
very issue it was a text message to dr
kipper where johnny depp said he cut off
his right finger to remind him not to
cut off the finger on his left hand and
of course he wasn't admitting that he
cut off his finger he was not being
literal he said it was similar
to saying something like you know i
bumped into a knife and so he basically
explained to the jury look he's been a
guitarist this is his life it's so
important to him he definitely would not
be cutting off his right or left finger
basically because that's so important to
him and i do think that one of the
things that depp and his attorneys
should do is to point out the fact that
as a right-handed person it would be
virtually impossible for him to cut off
the tip of his finger on his right hand
so he lied in the emergency room he
explained all that and i think that
he did a good job there and he said he
didn't want to implicate amber and he
didn't want to stop the production so
all good information yeah now angenette
after cross-examination had been done
they're trying to obviously poke holes
in dep's story do you think heard's
attorneys were successful in doing
that you know
it's hard to say because you don't
you're listening to this and you hear
the recordings and these like 11 12
second snippets and you think to
yourself wow this sounds awful but then
you hear the longer context of those
audio clips and and it's not excusing
the use of vulgar language or anything
like that or verbal uh verbally you know
possibly verbally abusive language but i
think that the matter that's really
interesting is the barrage of negative
news stories about johnny depp before
the op-ed that's really what this could
be about yeah i think there's a good
plan of attack but from what i
understand even when that barrage was
coming out he was still employed so i'm
going to see how that how uh depth
attorneys handle that but seem like a
red flag in my eyes at least well coming
up on law and crime daily a closer look
into the allegedly abusive relationship
of johnny depp and amber hur depp's
attorneys have the floor for redirect
examination how he says heard use his
childhood abuse against him
[Music]
welcome back our coverage continues now
in the johnny depp and amber heard
defamation trial on redirect depp said
he was fired from the pirates of the
caribbean franchise only days after
heard's op-ed was published after that
he spoke more about her alleged abuse
missouri was well aware of my past my
childhood
therefore
was
very adept at
knowing exactly
which buttons to push
so
at this point i mean i i felt like
well i was that little boy again in my
head like
i guess i'm i guess i'm the
i guess i am
incapable of doing anything right i
guess i will never be
happy i guess that
this is
who who i am
it's nothing that anyone could sustain
for any length of time it's it's nothing
that anyone should have to
sustain for any length of time when
you're being
demeaned berated
judged um
um and and and and and treated like a
lesser
animal
and treated as if uh
i'm only surrounded by yes men and i'm a
bad father and that
it was
these things were endless they they were
endless and they
there was there were there was no call
for them
it's hard to understand why someone that
is supposed to love you
um
could be that cruel
terry break down the purpose of redirect
for us and and how is depp doing so far
here
well the purpose of a redirect is to
make sure you rectify and clarify the
points on cross-examination and i think
she did a great job doing that she went
point by point she asked about that
washington post article she said
basically when he saw it he was
surprised he was shocked he was hurt
he also talked about the fact that
disney he found out about them dropping
him only after the article and one of
the other things i think she very much
clarified was
he wanted to play captain jack they made
it seem like first of all he wouldn't
have had a chance to do it but second of
all he didn't want to do it about the
300 million dollars in the 100
million llamas that he definitely didn't
want to do it but the the fact is he did
want to do it he wanted to make sure
that captain jack ended the right way so
i think she did a very good job of
clarifying all of the points that
cross-examination did especially the
point about uh being a monster and how
he looked at his drug addiction as being
the real monster yeah now karen that's
kind of like the factual standpoint one
thing that stood out to me it seemed as
depp's testimony continued there were
more and more objections as what do you
think the reason for that was and how
did it kind of shape the testimony
i believe that what the process the uh
ambrose attorneys were trying to do was
just to try to limit
the information that was going to be
coming out and so if we keep objecting
objecting and also we had a depth
attorney objecting as well i think what
it does if there's too many objections
it just causes the jury to get
frustrated it's like what are you trying
to keep out there's information that we
should know and and with these
objections for just being shut out yeah
definitely the optics and the strategy
behind it can be one or the other it's
gonna be cure i'm curious to see what
the jury says at the end of the day when
it comes to all this testimony coming in
but of course we'll keep you updated
here the law and crime network when we
come back the retrial of accused serial
killer billy shamirmir we head to texas
for opening statements in this
contentious case
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily in
texas opening statements are presented
in the retrial of accused serial killer
billy shamirmir in dallas monday a man
indicted on the murders of 18 elderly
women who died between 2016 and 2018 and
two neighboring counties
shamir mir is on trial for one of those
deaths lou harris an 81 year old
vietnamese immigrant who lived alone in
her home in plano texas it was another
incident that led police to shamirmir
another woman named mary annas bartel
was violently attacked in her apartment
at an independent residential community
for seniors also in plano police tracked
her attacker to shamirmir's apartment
he's charged with attempted murder in
the attack against bartel before his
arrest authorities say shamirmir tossed
a red jewelry box into a nearby dumpster
a key piece of evidence for the
prosecution because it contained the
name of lou harris inside the box
prosecutors argue shamir mir would pose
as a maintenance man or health care
worker to gain access to elderly
people's homes they say in a case of
louis harris shamirmir smothered her
with a pillow and stole her valuables
monday morning began with the court
addressing some last-minute issues and
waiting on a juror who was late then the
prosecution presented its opening
statement
you're going to hear about how this
individual right here
billy chamir
how he attacks not just one not just two
but three different individuals
in our county
leaving them for dead the charges that i
have to prove to you today is about one
lou t harris they were both checking out
at a walmart
at the corner of coit and arapahoe
he's in one aisle she's in the next
checking out the exact same time now
what you're going to hear is that about
two hours later around 5 50
mr chamiermeer is seen by the plano
police department
and he is at a dumpster and he is
throwing out significant individualized
items and when they go back to look at
the things that are in his hands as an
arrest and the things that he is
discarding into the trash
they realize
there's a name in here and that name is
lou t van her maiden name
the defense wave presenting its openings
until after the prosecution calls
witnesses
now terry indicted for killing 18 women
but only on trial for one bartel died in
2020 but the jury will see her recorded
testimony that's a lot going on at this
case so how do you think this is all
going to affect the jury in deciding
this case
you know i think this jury is going to
look at all of this evidence and try to
figure out what exactly happened
it's a fact that in the first trial
there was no opening statement by the
defense and i think that they're going
to have to go through all of the
evidence here to try to figure out what
did exactly happen and i don't know if
they're going to be able to this time
have a hung jury because
there is so much evidence at least based
on the prosecution's opening it does
seem as though there is a ton of
evidence there yeah and i know for the
prosecution their hurdle in the first
case was a bit of a misidentification i
don't think that harris really could
identify but a family member did say
that she typically gives two dollar
bills to people and a two dollar bill
was found on shamir mir you mentioned
about the opening statement now
interestingly enough like you said
didn't happen the first trial in this
second trial they're doing it again
they're reserving the right to do it
until after the prosecution's case so
does that make sense to you or should
they go should have gone right in and
attacked the case in opening
you know what brian it's interesting
because obviously the defense has the
right to reserve and not do an opening
statement and it does make sense because
they have an opportunity to see what the
evidence is to see what the prosecution
is going to say and i think it's a smart
move sometimes if you don't have a story
it's better to just sit back and wait of
course the jury wants to know what the
explanation is but if you can wait to
see what all the evidence is and then
wrap your story around that it's better
for the defense yeah and during the
opening and closing that kind of gives
them two bites of the apple well thank
you very much terry and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you